alors bonjour à tous nos auditeurs il
nous internautes autour de la planète
bienvenue à tam tam canada qui
aujourd'hui va plonger en plein mystère
pour lever le voile sur la sphère la
question des vaccins contre la grippe
non seulement sont ils efficaces mais
est ce qu'ils arrivent à être
complètement inoffensif et beaucoup de
beaucoup de choses qui se promène je
parlerai pas de virus mais des histoires
qui se promènent sur le web notamment au
canada qui influencent beaucoup notre
réaction
notre réaction anti viral ou anti
vaccins oui le l'engin active anti
vaccins officiellement les attend si les
deux fois que je me suis vacciné et
contre la grippe
j'ai eu des bribes d ma vie ici au
canada
ce que vous dites efficaces mais sont
ils vraiment efficaces ça dépend en fait
de la souche qui nous atteint cette
année là ça dépend de la nsa dépanner
anne-marie je me suis jamais fait
vacciner ou non cessa jamais parce que
c'est du passé c'est l'anti où ces deux
là se sont qu'un intérêt
non je suis pas tombé malade plus que
les autres d'ailleurs alors mairie
claude j'ai très rarement la grippe donc
j'ai jamais vu l'utilité de me faire
vacciner si vous êtes simplement une
personne en santé on attend une personne
qui pot vaccin ici at il une personne
par me levais vous si vous êtes pro
vacances peuvent accéder laglais contre
la grille jamais ça peut servir
évidemment les enfants très jeunes les
personnes âgées les gens qui ont des
problèmes de santé importants pour les
protéger mais si l'on parlait d'être des
vaccins de façon plus générale on va en
parler en musée moitié des missions de
cette affaire plus générale si vous
présentez d'accord pour le moment on
focalise sur cette grippe parce que 5
millions canadiens vont probablement
l'attraper
cette année et voici notre première
question remue ménage donc remuez vous
l'aimez neige et et on va savoir qui est
qui qui est le meilleur hélas vichy et
les enfants à l'école du pit fausse
exprime aussi la question du test
aujourd'hui zéro sur vingt est déjà pour
vous au caire aussi la question
marie-claude et l'état de marie et
paloma et leonardo la grippe dure à peu
près huit jours si on la soigne mais
combien de jours dure-t-elle si on ne
fait rien
combien de jours du retard en moyenne
cela ne fait rien ils sont cons
traitement en fait les plus forts c'est
une semaine
cette semaine quand vous l'avez loi
borloo
après ils savaient ce n'est cette jolie
on peut commencer à travailler après usl
1 7 jours marie-claude moi je dirais que
ces dix jours dix jours la même chose
c'est c 'est 8 journal et les familles
c'est la légion des choses qui jouent à
peu près aussi oui jours mais si la
bonne réponse la grippe ça dure huit
jours si on la soigne une semaine si on
ne fait rien
ça vous fait ça m'étonne pas c'est le
célèbre humoriste français raymond de la
saga fait rire là dessus on a tous donc
en souvenir quelque part que dans les
quelque part dans les consciences et de
ce soir là si vous le permettez je vais
vous demander on a un invité mystère qui
est en bout de ligne ici quito sur le
skype de tam-tam canada avant de le
hibou ici tant titimal est une image de
groupe plein de notre survie
il est là d'accord alors en
l'accueillant je vais vous demander quel
serait un remède de grand-mère favori
pour combattre la grippe que vous n'avez
jamais paloma remettre de grand-mère
tisane avec du citron est du mien
exactement ce que j'allais dire violent
c'est fantastique et autres choses des
capsules d'ecc menacé et kirui ken a
cessé très populaire aussi rester à la
maison et quand et le moins de monde
possible qui serait atteint du fameux
virus
écoutez on a évité un spécialiste ici du
québec le docteur gaston de serres
médecin épidémiologiste
oui ça existe c'est une histoire des
piles et des logiques
il travaille à l'institut national de la
santé publique du québec dr de serres
bonjour il a accepté sans délai
contrairement à skype de cette émission
alors c'est fantastique
écoutez on a beaucoup de mythes comme ça
qu'on entretient beaucoup de croyances
et aussi à beaucoup de choses qui
circulent sur le web concernant les
dangers entre guillemets de ses
campagnes de vaccination contre la
grippe
dites-moi est-ce qu'il ya encore quelque
chose qui vous fait rugir de colère ou
de vous lever les bras en l'air ça n'a
pas d'alluré en 2017 qu'on dise encore
des âneries au sujet des vaccins contre
la grippe
ici au canada je peux pas dire quelque
chose qui me fasse rire il ya plusieurs
choses qui ont été dites je pense qu'ils
ont tant de l'importance d'abord il faut
savoir que durant l'hiver
il ya beaucoup d'infections
respiratoires et quand on teste des gens
qui ont des symptômes de grippe non qui
font de la fière
car mal à la gorge qui tous et c'est à
peu près le tiers de ces gens alors on
va voir la crypte vrai les autres d'une
tierce et des gens qui sont infectés par
d'autres microbes que le microbe de la
grille et donc quand on dit j'ai su le
vaccin de la grippe et malgré ça j'ai eu
la grippe
il faut savoir que souvent ce qu'on a
eue ce n'était pas la grippe est
évidemment le vaccin de la grippe n'est
pas efficace contre les autres virus
respiratoires alors le nôtre si le
premier c'est le deuxième point il ya
plusieurs personnes qui ont dit moi je
savais qu'on oui alors gelé la
communication oui vous êtes perdus
écoutez vous êtes capable de rétablir la
communication
alors oui on vous a perdu pour les 30
dernières secondes que disiez-vous
achard spécialistes désolé je ne sais
quoi si vous avez manqué la partie où je
disais que un tiers des gens qui a des
symptômes de grippe ont vraiment la
grille mais non sans quelques bons et
l'autre partie c'est que un adulte en
général on calcule que le risque de
faire la grippe
et de cinq pour cent par année ce qui
veut dire qu'un adulte sur mail 5 pour
ça le différent à chaque année on va
faire un épisode symptomatique de grippe
à chaque 20 à 3 c'est donc ce n'est pas
surprenant que plusieurs personnes
disaient je ne me souviens pas de la
dernière fois où j'ai fait la guerre
ceci étant dit le vaccin de la grippe
comme l'audi une des personnes autour de
la table c'est quand même une catégorie
différente de la vaccination
pédiatriques donc levac ce qu'ont
annoncé les enfants sont très efficaces
92 95 pour ça est vraiment quand on
parle du vaccin de la grippe
c'est une classe à part qui n'a pas du
tout la même efficacité que la
vaccination contre les maladies
pédiatriques est donc à ce niveau là
nous
qui sont des jeunes adultes en bonne
santé qui disent est ce que vraiment
pour moi le vaccin de la grippe c'est
important ben il faut voir que un adulte
qui va faire la guerre pour avoir deux
trois jours ou liées à faire la fièvre a
pas mal partout etc
on va tous et pendant une dizaine de
jours mais les risques d'hospitalisation
ou de décès sont très faibles et ceci
est très différent pour les personnes
âgées ou si on prend les personnes de 75
ans et plus qui constituent la majorité
des gens qui vont être hospitalisés ou
qui vont décéder de la grippe mais pour
eux la grippe a des conséquences
beaucoup plus graves et pour eux même si
le vaccin de la grippe moins efficace
que nos vaccins pédiatriques
les conséquences sont tellement plus
grave que ça vaut quand même la peine
d'utiliser le vaccin docteur de serre
j'aimerais comprendre un peu la
situation particulière des canadiens
nous on vit dans des maisons renfermé
l'hiver comme ça entre nous tous un peu
comme des dans des igloos et je voulais
savoir ce qu'on a tendance à avoir plus
souvent la grippe que par exemple des
gens qui habitent un peu plus au sud par
exemple qui habite à washington à la
maison blanche
[Rires]
j'ai un peu mal pris de perdre par
exemple il ya des grandes différences
entre les pays zones tempérées et les
pays tropicaux dans les pays tropicaux
haut lieu de la guerre
mais la grippe n'a pas un aspect
épidémique qui ressemble à celui qu'ont
d'heure dans l'hémisphère nord et
l'hémisphère sud dans les pays tempérés
de ces deux hémisphères la peur donc
l'hémisphère nord les pays tempérés
avoir des saisons et puis des mecs très
marqué alors que dans les autres
l on avait plutôt une circulation à bas
bruit l'homme et qui va se prolonger par
là deux mois paloma en fait je voulais
poser la question aussi constamment
c'est la distribution géographique de la
grippe parce que je me souviens que au
mexique
il y a eu là
inde et puis de l'épidémie de h1n1
je pense que c'était en hausse annuelle
des beauvières non d'entrer après c'est
un autre type degrés et puis il ya eu
une grande épidémie pile beaucoup de
gens sont décédées au mexique
donc voilà j'avais juste une question
concernant la distribution géographique
de ce type de grippe
est-ce que ça est ce que l'âme droit à
la nuance la grippe dans le parler c'est
la grippe que eu lieu en 2009 donc la
pandémie de 2009 a été géré est un peut
pas démarrer mais identifié et est le
premier lieu on a vraiment dit qu'il y
avait un problème c'était au mexique
mais arrive à monter il ya des
identifications qui avait été fait en
californe promis donc est ce que c'est
de la californie ou du mexique que par
la grippe de 2009
il ya encore un débat là dessus mais ça
semble plutôt être aux états unis que ça
a commencé
ceci dit ce site a dit donc la grippe
est une maladie qui circulent dirais à
large échelle
donc quand ça circule au canada aux
états unis au mexique ça circule à peu
près en même temps en aurait pas russie
et en chine doivent vraiment plein de
maladies qui ont une distribution
planétaire et même si elle est bonne
différence de température par exemple
entre washington et québec
on aura à peu près la grippe à la même
période
ben d'acteurs dessin j'apprécie beaucoup
votre réponse à cette superbe question
moi je lui ai répondu plus rapidement
c'est sûr ça a une influence au mexique
après ça on après tout on appelle ça
n'influence a très sérieusement je dois
vous faire entendre parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de campagne sur le web des
campagnes virales contre les vaccins
j'en ai j'en ai noté plusieurs heures
durant notre recherche qu'on a effectué
cette semaine en préparation à cette
émission une envoyé par un homme est ce
donc ces voyous du web qui tentent de
rétablir
un équilibre des fois aussi je me
stabilise et jours alors je voulais pas
passer de propagande comme ça à
l'antenne de radio-canada ce n'est pas
mon rôle mais c'était mon rôle
d'informer sur ce qui se passe et j'ai
possédé donc un petit montage d'une
vidéo anonymus à écouter donc et
professeurs professeur vous êtes
professeur quelque part mes docteurs de
serre vous écouter ensuite vous avez
réagir d'accord merci
en écoutant de nombreux experts médicaux
s'accordent aujourd'hui sur le fait
qu'il est plus important pour vous et
votre famille de vous protéger du vaccin
contre la jeune bahia grippe elle-même
chaque année l'industrie pharmaceutique
les experts médicaux et les principaux
médias travaillent dur seront janata de
se faire vacciner contre la grippe
non ne nous dit pas toute l'histoire ce
que nous n'entendons pas ce sont des cas
sur les effets indésirables ou sur les
produits chimiques toxiques comme nous
injecte pour lesquels les vaccins contre
la grippe sont plus dangereux que la
grippe elle-même première raison en fait
le vaccin contre la grippe
rome est là pour commencer avez vous
déjà remarqué comment les enfants
vaccinés tombe malade
presque immédiatement après une
vaccination deuxième raison les vaccins
antigrippaux contiennent d'autres
ingrédients dangereux tels que le
mercure jamais rien attendu aux mêmes
raisons le vaccin contre la grippe
spécialiste en immunologie on a class
heroes régulièrement le vaccin contre la
grippe d'avoir l'âme alors que même les
jeunes souffrent bénéficier de vaccins
contre la grippe
c'est fait donc ça ce sera un problème
technique a réglé la semaine prochaine
nous permettent à nos invités d'entendre
sky pendant que boston exactement je
vous résume la sphère principalement il
y avait cinq arguments aux arguments en
fait qui donnent m contre les vaccins et
1,2 entre eux c'était que les gens qui
sont vaccinées ton souvent
dans les jours dans les minutes qui
suivent même alors il ya aussi qu'il ya
du mercure dans les vaccins ou encore
qui a des échantillons de certains types
d'aluminium louis 1 dans les vaccins
donc d'aider des produits que les gens y
ont associé dans le passé à des
problèmes de santé très sérieux par
exemple mercure et alzheimer mais c'est
pas un peu normal qu'on tournait
légèrement malade après le vaccin
puisque on s'est fait inoculé le virus
de la grippe docteur ya plusieurs
éléments qui ont été dits visite d'un
produit à base de mercure le thimerosal
est un produit qui est mis dans les
fioles de vaccin parce que devant leur
stand entre une première aiguille pour
prendre une première belge à un peu
contaminé le dax sur bactéries y ait
besoin d'un agent de préservation et le
thimérosal et d'un agent t-il de
conservation dans lesquelles vous une
molécule de mercure c'est vrai la
capacité d'un berthouloux cuba elle est
vraiment infime
et quand on parle de maladies dues aux
intoxication au mercure donc les aides
maladie qui s'appelle la maladie de
minamata on parle pas de quantité
semblable à ce qu'on donne sur une
baisse de l'action on parle de quantités
la mer des milliers de fois plus grande
que ça donc je pense que c'est certain
que quand on dit mon père que ça nous
fait un peu
tremblay où ça nous inquiète et était
évidemment quelque chose qui est très
importante
quand on parle de d'intoxication la même
chose pour l'aluminium donc dans les
vaccins dans certains vaccins pour les
ans enfin on dort l'aluminium qui est un
agent qui augmente la capacité de notre
système immunitaire de détecter sur ce
qu'on a mis dans le vaccin pour remonter
pas de réponse immunitaire non encore la
quantité d'uranium qui est présente
d'accès elle est extrêmement faible
donc je pense que il ya du vrai dans ce
qui est dit mais il ya du flou dans
l'interprétation de ce qui est vrai donc
oui de l'aluminium
oui à du mercure non ces deux
composantes le sont sont pas en
quantités suffisamment élevé pour être
dommageable est ce que le docteur de
serre à calmer vos appréhensions vos
soucis vos préoccupations et vous allez
maintenant allez vous faire vacciner
mais en fait je voulais savoir est ce
que un peu tombés malades après avoir
reçu le vaccin quelques jours après la
ce que prétendent elles anonymus bon
alors je pense que les vaccins ce sont
des produits pour stimuler le système
immunitaire et comme vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure ça va être de libérer le
système d'allibert des produits qu'on
appelle des cytokines qui va stimuler
l'apparition parfois de faire des fautes
douleurs musculaires avec cette année
donc c'est normal d'avoir une réaction
après le vaccin
même si la grande majorité des gens
vaccinés n'ont aucune réaction
perceptive des vrais mythe qui existe
c'est que lorsqu'on reçoit le vaccin
on va développer la maladie alors ça
c'est vraiment un mythe
le vaccin ne contient pas de virus
vivants par les vaccins en injection le
vaccin en vaporisation qui est donné
surtout chez les jeunes enfants lui un
virus vivants qui est adapté à se
développer uniquement dans le nez donc
on dit que c'est un virus elle adapte
un froid il ne peut pas se multiplier
ailleurs que dans le nez qui ont une
température qui est inférieur à la
température général de notre cas donc il
n'ya pas non plus de virus qui va se
répandre dans le corps il va nous donner
la maladie on peut avoir la malchance
des vaccinés puis après avoir une grippe
mais d'une autre genre de grippe dit
vrai problème c'est que le vaccin qu'on
a est un vaccin qui ça va devenir un des
opéras ceux qui il ya le vaccin de la
grippe n'a pas une efficacité très élevé
ça varie d'une année à l'autre on dit
entre 30 et 60% des pendant des années
et évidemment sauce c'est beaucoup moins
bon que la performance qu'on a avec nos
autres vaccins donc à cet égard là c'est
certainement décevant de de se faire
vacciner et malgré tout de faire la
maladie et attend parlait donc de tout
votre groupe vous êtes déjà adulte qui
apparaissait
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
le bénéfice pour vous de vous faire
vacciner si on si vous faites vacciner à
chaque année pour les prochaines années
vous allez réduire votre risque à peu
près de moitié donc au lieu de faire une
grille par vingt ans vous allez faire
une grille par 40 ans bon c'est sûr le
dit comme ça c'est pas trop attrayant
mais par contre je reviens à l'exemple
initiale des personnes âgées
si on parle des personnes âgées lorsqu
elles attrapent la grippe
beaucoup d'entre elles vont aboutir à
l'hôpital et 5 à 10 % celles qui sont
hospitalisés vont être décédé donc là
évidemment on parle d'un danger beaucoup
plus grand et donc la recommandation
vise d'abord les personnes âgées les
personnes avec des maladies chroniques
sévères et et les adultes en bonne santé
cette décision qui vous revient mais ce
sont les animateurs de radio vous faites
ce que vous voulez mais il faut quand
même dire que la vaccination d'être est
important pour les enfants pour tous les
enfants qui suivent les douze je sais
pas combien des malades et des vaccins
qui reçoivent je crois que c'est
fondamental de dire que c'est important
de les vacciner
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai
commencé en disant les vaccins des
enfants c'est une catégorie tout à fait
différente appartiennent aux catégories
tout à fait différente du vaccin de la
grippe
ce sont les vaccins beaucoup plus
efficace pour des maladies qui sont très
sérieuses et donc clairement les vaccins
des enfants sont chaudement recommandée
et sans exception alors via leurs
enfants jusqu'à quel âge d'aucuns savent
à lui les calendriers commence à partir
de l'âge de 2 mois pour les enfants donc
actuellement il ya des visites à deux
mois 4 mois 6 mois 1 à 18 mois il y en a
jean prisca l'aréna en 4e année alors
secondaire 3 donc il ya plusieurs
groupes répartis durant toute l'enfance
et l'adolescence très bien on va vous
laisser partir vous êtes très occupé
jusque nous certainement vous pouvez
laisser rentrer votre fille a pas de
problème
c'est fini merci beaucoup d'acteurs
d'avoir pris le temps de nous parler dr
gaston de serres médecin épidémiologiste
à l'institut national de santé publique
du canada
mais dites moi c'est pas votre médecin
donc non non non
s'ils écoutent et inka quand on parle
musée cote us assez rare chez certains
médecins loger des médecins tous les
jours je ne peux pas me faire vacciner
et je vous prends demandé on va aller
rapidement vers un autre dossier qui
préoccupe beaucoup les parents partis
allemands au québec parce que c'est un
peu nouveau à grande échelle comme ça
mais ailleurs dans le canada aussi les
jeunes garçons les jeunes filles d'abord
qui ont reçu le vaccin contre le vph
donc le pilote donc une grande campagne
qui a lieu en ce moment par exemple au
québec beaucoup de temps qu'ils se
posent des questions à ce que je devrais
je devrais pas est ce que finalement et
on prend pas plus de risques que les
risques de maladies éventuelle de
contracter le cancer en raison de
relations sexuelles avant dans un jeune
âge avant l'âge de 19 ans je voulais
vous amener vers je veux faire un petit
peu d informations je veux dire que
c'est à dessein formation le fait que
ces bons textes vrai le docteur michel
georget auteur de plusieurs ouvrages sur
la vaccination en france qui est à
l'antenne et tf1 des grandes antennes
qui fait le tour et on les écoute et un
message anti vaccins par rapport au vph
est peut-être que ça trouvant un écho
ici au québec
en tout cas il reprend des arguments qui
sont souvent déployés ici au canada on
va l'écouter donc dans cette vidéo
numéro 3 écouter les arguments contre le
fait de vagues de faire vacciner vos
enfants de 14 15 ans contre le sait plus
jeunes
alors voici ce qu'il dit une partie de
qui dit il parle également du canada
j'ai trouvé par exemple sur un site
officiel du ministère de la santé du
canada que pour les vaccins d'une façon
générale et c'est vrai aussi pour ce
vaccin contre les papillomavirus aucune
recherche concernant la toxicité sur la
reproduction et la toxicité sur les ce
qu'on appelle l'art pro toxicité est
bien né n'est requise pour les
vaccinations
or là nous avons affaire à des vaccins
qui touche la sphère génitale et ce qui
est à craindre c'est qu'on se retrouve
dans quelques années peut-être avec des
problèmes comparables à ceux qui ont été
engendrées par le distilbène
vous savez c'est ce médicament cette
hormone de synthèse qui a été prise par
les femmes
il y a une trentaine d'années pendant
leur grossesse et qui ont conduit à des
cancers pour ces femmes et surtout à des
anomalies génitales et à des cancers
chez la descendance
les filles de ces mères qui ont été
traités par le distilbène ont beaucoup
de difficultés ont eu beaucoup de
difficultés à avoir des enfants et on en
est aujourd'hui où la génération
suivante aux petits enfants dont les
filles et même les garçons peuvent
présenter des anomalies de l'appareil
génital et voir des développement de
cancers et on a donc là un exemple de
transmission à travers les générations
d'une toxicité des médicaments et il
n'est pas du tout impossible qu'une
telle toxicité soit retrouvez aussi tous
le vaccin contre le cancer du col
essentiellement ces arguments c'est
qu'on prend beaucoup des risques pour
pas grand chose puisqu'il dit des
statistiques c'est le 20ème cancer
atteignant les femmes en france alors
que henry stade 1 on peut guérir 60% à 2
40% au stade 3 30% au stade 4 20% et aux
bus de la ligne peu de personnes qui en
meurent au canada j'ai regardé les
chiffres c'est le 20ème cancer qui
touche la femme
ça c'est pour le col maintenant pour le
corps du terrain c'est un peu plus
sérieuses et 8e cancer mais tout de même
niveau des décès une femme sur 475 alors
que cancers de la femme cancer de femmes
cancer du sein oui une femme sont en
droit d'avoir et beaucoup en décèdent
alors voilà ça c'est simple à lui 10 ans
du ministère de la santé du québec ni du
ministère de la santé du canada
donc il faut il faut être informé il
faut lire tout ce qui a à lire
certainement d'institutions publiques
officielles parce que sinon c'est la
meilleure manière de s'informer et
chômage avant d'avoir un débat ici
autour de la table sur le fond et le
compte de ces informations qu'on peut
capter comme ça voici la version plus
officielle et gouvernementales elle
viendra du canada un reportage plus
court que j'ai monté ici pour faire
entendre les principaux arguments en
faveur de la vaccination te d'ivoire que
c'est cissé sur le docteur c'était noir
ainsi tout blanc on écoute
aujourd'hui on peut lire ya pas mal de
parents inquiets à propos du vaccin
contre le vph un vaccin qui est donné
chaque année à des élèves à travers le
pays est-ce que ce vaccin est ce qu'on
le méritait
[Musique]
d'abord est-ce que c'est vrai que le
vaccin ne protège pas contre tous les
types de vph
oui c'est vrai parce qu'il existe une
centaine de types du virus du papillome
humain
le vaccin protège contre 9 2 cv ph est
ce que c'est vrai que des personnes sont
mortes après avoir été vaccinée la
compagnie muc a testé deux gros un
groupe avec le premier vaccin qu'elle a
développé le gardasil et l'autre groupe
avec le gardasil 9 chacun des groupes
le cinq personnes qui sont décédées mais
regardez les causes accident de voiture
écrasement d'avion suicide hémorragie
cérébrale leucémie choc septique
blessures par balles tu meurs
manifestement mort inexpliquée
en aucun cas on a été capable de faire
le lien entre les morts et le vaccin bon
et puis l'éternelle question est ce que
c'est vrai que ce vaccin provoque
beaucoup d'effets secondaires une bonne
respiration au québec depuis 2008 sur
près d'un million de doses 330 personnes
vaccinées contre le vph ont eu des
effets secondaires inhabituels une
réaction allergique par exemple ou
encore une rougeur sur la peau si tu
faisais un petit peu de fierté
manga maman te donner du cinéma
l'organisation mondiale de la santé le
considère comme un vaccin extrêmement
sûres alors voilà le pour et le contre
et vous étiez vous avez déjà vu se
rapporter un jeune arrive en parfaite
dans ce parce que je suis souvent ce que
fait la vie rythmée j'avais pas vu ce
reportage en particulier bon alors c'est
des arguments intéressants là on voit
que il ya une campagne virale contre
quelque chose mais là quand on creuse on
a le temps de creuser on a des journées
c'était jean professionnels qui sont des
artistes ont creusé des choses véritable
ils obtiennent des informations qui les
gens qui ont eu des problèmes et sont
décédés de choses à fait contraire qu'il
a le vaccin avec leur mort entendez les
la vidéo quand c'est dans un moment
donné a dit que c'était neuf souche qui
était atteinte avec le vaccin oui en
fait sur une seule vie oui mais ce qui
provoque même mais c'est qu'ils
provoquent les camps sans doute plus
c'est sûrement 4 1 las seis 18 31 et 45
sont les responsables de pouvoir
développer impossibilité de cancer oui
c'est pas nécessaire que tu vas voir un
cancer comme toi ces cépages là mais tu
peux vous pourrez la voir alors ça
soulève des questions c'est beaucoup
d'eux de beaucoup de prix d'initiative
beaucoup d'argent dépensé beaucoup de
ressources mobilisées pour essayer de de
contrer un problème qui est petit ou
plus petit qu'on le pensait initialement
qu'on ne peut des fois le capter dans
des campagnes publicitaires
ça soulève les questions bon si un
vaccin pour 6 ou pour ça ce qu'on doit
tous les prend un nouvel essor
je pense que les vaccins il faudrait les
prendre parce que on parle de mk dans
400 personnes mais quand même c'est mk
que les systèmes santé il faut qu'ils
aillent traités et ses traitements
c'est pas si sharks et vacciner
seulement 1
je pense que s'il ya une question
d'argent toujours le bain mais je
connais si on a trouvé un vaccin qui
peut peut-être empêché un cancer de se
développer
c'est déjà une grande réussite parce
qu'on n'a pas trouvé un vaccin qui
puisse empêcher les cancers du sein de
se développer ni d'autres dons sur vous
de souza les codes c'est exactement dans
le cadre du papillon mais en fait c'est
il ya plusieurs cancers qui sont kyson
lee qui pourraient être évités pour être
empêché de développer et oui l'utérus le
col de l'utérus mais il ya aussi les
pénis il ya aussi d'autres parce que
maintenant on ne donne ce même vaccin
aux garçons aussi parce que donc il y a
plusieurs
car ce qui pourrait éviter donc ceci le
pour et le contre qu'il faut les gens
sont capables d'évaluer les informations
on n'est pas là pour tous puisque
beaucoup de gens ne font pas vacciner
que ce soit le vph ou le vpm plus tôt ou
d'autres ou d'autres maladies encore
beaucoup de gens qui ne font pas
vacciner en france il ya quelque chose
de nouveau qui s'en vient la france se
sentent très souvent un peu plus
socialiste pour un peu trop mais un peu
plus socialiste maurice a poliment la
fille un peu plus socialiste que nous au
québec et des au québec on est très
socialiste perçu doigts de la maison
blanche à washington par exemple alors
en france qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
marie-claude déjà en france il ya des
vaccins obligatoires donc difficile au
tournant c'est en a trois qui sont
l'homme ambulatoire contre la diphtérie
le tétanos et la poliomyélite
mais en janvier à partir de 2018 en
janvier et s'il en avant huit autres qui
vont s'ajouter donc coqueluche rougeole
oreillons rubéole est passé dans fait
tout ce qu'on fait pour nos enfants ici
mais oui c'est pas obligatoire on peut
encore un peu envoyez nato en disant je
veux pas que mon enfant
voici la question question tam-tam
canada cette semaine d'autres y ont
répondu sur l'internet merci beaucoup
la france rend obligatoire en janvier
prochain la vaccination de tous les
enfants contre 11 maladie devrions-nous
limitée ou pas je vais on va se limiter
à quelques réactions d'autant plus que
les gens nous internautes se sont
limités seulement quelques réactions
xavier houssin qui habitent ici au
québec
imiter ou être conscient point
d'interrogation la question est ce qu'on
fait comme tous les autres on y
réfléchit d'abord mamies et les rames
elle dit non en lettres majuscules ça
veut dire en langage d'internautes niet
et puis françoise depardieu en france ça
doit bien faire un mois et demi que nous
avait pas écrit et elle réagit la de la
grippe non votant même chose mais quel
type est préoccupé et non elle était
occupée ces enfants qui vont à l'école
certainement un part de ses gros enfants
à chaque fois qu'elle le veut qu'elle le
peut de madame depardieu alors je suis
masseube bayeux à la magic mouse et je
l'imaginé avec la vois des mecs mais
j'ai pas l'accent je suis contre les
maladies mortelles par dit loeb n'a pas
hésité pas l'accent mais je n'ai pas
confiance dans les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques je pense que cette
mesure de vaccination obligatoire va
surtout profiter à l'industrie
la médecine se laissent acheter par les
laboratoires je n'ai aucune confiance et
elle poursuit en disant cela exigerait
une transparence totale sur l'efficacité
véritable de tous ces vaccins avec des
tests faits par des labos indépendance
selon moi je ne pense pas qu'il y a une
véritable urgence au niveau de la santé
pour nous imposer 8 vaccins obligatoires
supplémentaires
et elle conclut en disant je pense que
l'état répond aux pressions des labos
qui veulent faire encore plus d'argent
heureusement que mes deux gros garçons
de 16 et 17 ans n'auront pas attendre
l'épaule pour cette histoire la grisante
et on imagine
et un bon of tanks les deux gros bisous
à la paix promise et on espère qu'il est
comme alan parce que nous on a peur des
microbes de la france mais la question
elle est sérieuse est ce que il ya ces
sous-entendus dans sa dans sa réponse
est ce qu'il y à des patients économique
n'a par des labos enfin des vaccins au
gouvernement et le gouvernement 10 bat
finalement si tu veut nous vendre des
vaccins pourquoi pas nous on a d'argent
ça vient de partout
la question est en droit de se poser je
suis poisson mais moi j'ai élevé trois
enfants
j'ai fait vacciner mes enfants dans des
bouquins et dax nation et j'ai toujours
cru que c'était obligatoire
je me pose est celle de mon enfant
s'était divisée c'était vraiment
moitié-moitié ya des gens qui ne
voulaient absolument pas à les faire
vacciner leurs enfants et d'autres comme
moi qu'ils ont fait moi je vous protéger
les autres sinon c'est les vacances au
bnd qui vont à vis et des maladies qui
on connaît déjà qui s'affaisse un tas
qui ont fait des vaccins oui parce que
l'on connaît mais ces vaccins chi chi
minh sens et qui ne sait pas qui est
parce que riz on parle des possibilités
des problèmes avec les le vph les vph
les ps mais l'histoire c'est qu'on n'a
pas des cas encore des gens qui a pu
l'être aimé n'y a pas de cas suspect 4 k
swiss tic en espagnol jusqu'à quand ya
pas d cadre du grand débat c'est vrai
que les nouvelles le nouveau vaccin ça
nous on se pose toutes sortes de
questions je me suis posé la question
avec ma fille de 8 ans qu'elle en est
net des neuf ans que l'année dernière a
eu son vaccin pour le contre le vph
sur le coup je me suis dit j'ai pas des
preuves pour dire que ce n'est pas
efficace
donc pour l'instant je vais te protège
et puis je veux qu'on protège les soucis
au dos de autour de nous donc on
retrouve tous les faits de problème
je voudrais qu'on se quitte sur quelque
chose de spécial qui va nous ramener 100
ans en arrière presque maintenant 100
ans en arrière
[Musique]
ces deux musiques typiques du québec
c'est bien c'est la première et à 10
[Rires]
marie-claude merci beaucoup pour cette
semaine on va se quitter donc sur ce
nous l'air sonore sera bientôt visuel
alors leonardo gimeno merci beaucoup
merci et n arrivons oui les citations
pour les deux prix remporter notre
équipe et du président le prix du
président de radio canada pour
l'inclusion parce qu'il était temps
d'inclure la parole autochtone à radio
chalco là alors on est très fiers
d'avoir reçu ça c'est pas le précieux le
prix du président américain
on est fier de vous non non non c'est le
cas nous allons rester avec le prix du
président de radio canada il cible ici
quand même ce à l'échelle du canada
donc une personnalité publique
maintenant inquiète avec nous et puis un
jour un petit ami au plus tôt les
navettes et d'accès de la santé et puis
paloma martinez merci beaucoup donc 100
ans en arrière et quelques poussières ou
de -1 donc autour des années fin des
années 20 début les années 30
vous l'avez vous souvenez d'elle c'est
la première afin avoir envoyé des
fausses nouvelles sur le web ou enfin
presque
la bolduc qui chantait alors deviner jeu
la grippe
[Musique]
on a une épidémie simplement de son vip
et d'un apport de mes amis on parle un
truc cette année tous les matins 500
répondants 52 lots témouchent c'est pas
doué pour ce sont leurs unes de tabloïds